you posted maybe a cryptic Instagram
that have people confused can you clear
the air at all we don't know what
happened
Toni Braxton sets the record straight on
her romance with Birdman the photo in
question this one posted January 1st
with the caption starting a new chapter
isn't always an easy choice but always
choose to be chosen okay we'll just ride
with it cuz that would give us some
privacy but so that's good things are
all good all right Tony the last time
there was a Braxton Family Values
premiere the Braxtons were not there
stuff was going down how did we work
through all that drama all the a yon
love to get to tonight without loving
each other at that moment we always
was it at all a difficult decision to
come back and do the show together yeah
I'm the oldest so you know I'm the one
that kind of try to put it all together
all the time but we just love each other
we fight hard I mean really hard but we
love it home yeah we see in the trailers
fight hard with each other but also
fight hard for each other
Tracy nearly goes to blows for you in
that trailer what's it like to see that
you know her and B they can't have that
relationship they find it in the next
minute they're on the couch eating
popcorn kind of their thing that's kind
of what we've come to expect in the
Braxtons world have you had to boil this
season down to one word how would you
describe it one word that's so hard with
my family no oh god it's a Braxton thing
though I can't what would you say I
think family drama I'll take those two
words because that's what that's what
the show is what's going to surprise the
viewers about this new set of episodes
but they kind of know that but there's a
little teeny twist this season I can't
give it away just like the cliffhanger
about you maybe my Toni Braxton did you
see Tamar impersonated you on Instagram
the other day but I don't think I do my
lips like that the lips the lip service
was not correct
I'm sorry incorrect can you do at a more
impression for me no I can't treat us
really good at the table arm pressure
like that's our thing
it's not my thing I'm not good at them
and then you just wrapped up a tour how
are you doing health-wise today's a good
day this morning with all the shaky
where right now it's a good day I'm
hungry